what you do is more important than how
you do it and put another way being
effective is more important than being
efficient
[Music]
one of the things you talk about in the
for our work week is an elimination you
talk about I don't like productivity and
I think most time management is you know
in some sense a waste of time this is
smart people spending too much time
trying to be more efficient instead of
trying to be smarter about what they do
and I recently did this big piece for
the New Yorker on it was called the rise
and fall of getting things done and it
was about the rise of the productivity
prawn movement which was this movement
that felt like with the right high-tech
tools and scripts and database backed
applications you could basically make
work you could tame all your work and it
would be easy an interesting thing about
that timeline is that that movement
picked up all of its speed into three or
four years before the four hour work
week came out and around the time the
four hour work week came out the main
one of the main organs of that which was
uh Merlin man's 43 folders blog which
was a really important thing at the time
oh it's hugely influential yeah
basically not shut down but it
redirected away from this isn't going to
work that's kind of the point of this
article is it followed Merlin's story
but it was like okay we're not going to
solve work by just having Quicksilver
scripts and kgtd like actually we need
to rethink work all of that was
concurrent so when you're looking at
productivity is not working time
management is not working
is that what you were seeing that moment
of that that brief moment of optimism
where we thought was like the right Mac
configurations we can make our
overwhelming work effortless without
having to actually ask the question of
what our work is you might not remember
I mean this is a while ago no I remember
a lot of it I think that last portion is
true for me at least in the sense that
the cult of productivity we have to be
very careful with that term and you've
written about this I read your recent
piece actually which I thought was very
good we have to Define productivity very
carefully yes lest we become
yeah you know the Greyhound chasing this
rabbit around a track not knowing why
we're there in the first place but I
think technologists
and those who are
mesmerized by technologists and
Technology are very prone
to getting extremely
efficient at doing things that are not
important
and sometimes sometimes they do apply to
things that are important but the thrust
of the four hour work week I would say
in a nutshell is
what you do is more important than how
you do it and put another way being
effective is more important than being
efficient so let's think really hard
about
the 80 20 principle otherwise known as
pareto's law
such that
if you focus on the highest Leverage
things even if you [ __ ] up every which
way from Sunday you have such a margin
of safety and such a disproportionate
output for the time that you put in it's
okay
does that make sense so if you look at
a Churchill Drucker I mean a lot of
these figures who were massively
productive by almost any definition I
mean taking naps you got like Ulysses S
Grant alcoholic you know it's not like
they were sitting in front of a
typewriter or dictating or active
frenetically active all the time that
was just not the case so yeah yeah I
agree with you and I think anyone who
has attempted to
kind of address the malaise of overwork
by adding more tools and tricks and
Scripts
realizes pretty quickly that the water
is always going to fill faster than you
can bail it out with that type of
approach at least in my experience yeah
I think that idea is very influential
for me too I got it from you I'm pretty
you know I got that from the far work
week but I thought about it recently I
wrote an essay over the summer where I
read a book about the history of all the
a lot of great scientists throughout the
history of Science and I wrote this
essay that was saying Galileo didn't
work that much and yet we see him as
being incredibly productive but he was
never he was rarely busy that's so far
our work week idea I just want to say
one more thing because it's so tangible
for folks a lot of people
don't identify with Scientists or maybe
even writers but this is true of a lot
of the world's best investors also I
mean Warren Buffett don't just do
something stand there instead of don't
just stand there do something and dairy
laziness bordering on sloth I think is
how either he or Monger have described
their investing approach you don't have
to do a lot if you get a few things
right and if you really pick your
targets well
okay good now that you brought it up let
me just as an aside pitch you this this
is this idea I've been developing on my
podcast recently slow productivity yeah
and here's my whole concept I don't know
let's see if this makes sense
productivity depends on scale
So when you say what I want to do is
maximize what I produce on the scale of
weeks you're going to be very very busy
let's get things moving emails going
back and forth I'm jumping on calls or
what have you but if you change the
scale to years
like I want to maximize what I produce
over the next five years to be as
impressive as possible it's like a
completely different game because now
it's like I want to produce three great
things in the next five years which
means your Wednesday you might do
nothing right it's like scale so this is
my this is my new thing maybe scale the
scale at which you're talking about
producing changes the the rhythm of what
your everyday every day feels like but
this is all aspirational for me because
I have too much going on so yeah I I
love that phrasing slow productivity or
like patient productivity is maybe
another way to to look at it and not to
revert back to investing over and over
again but money is such a
important tangible scary alluring thing
to people that it's useful as an
instrument when talking about some of
these principles and I read a book
recently well listen to a book called
the psychology of money by Morgan
Hassell and I was quite impressed by it
and one of the chapters explored
the importance of playing your own game
and not other people's games but that
entails knowing what games they are
playing so for instance if you have
momentum traders who are in very short
positions who really don't care if let's
just use an arbitrary example if Google
has a higher price a year from now but
they do care they don't care about
fundamentals anything like that free
cash flow whatever they don't care about
any of that what they do care about is
sort of Market sentiment or behavior
driving up the price that they can sell
tomorrow or a week later and
it's important to kind of know the
motivations and the games of other
participants
because if you have a different time
Horizon your way of relating to that is
totally different
for instance like can I guess
this is not investment advice but like
again I guess
can I guess correctly whether Stock's
going to go up or down by what
percentage over the next week no over a
year no probably not I mean any kind of
cataclysm could hit but there are
certain Trends over time where it's like
yeah do I think there are certain
technologies that inescapably are going
to become more pervasive in a five to
ten year stretch and if I invest in
companies that are investing heavily in
those areas do have a pretty high
degree of confidence is going to go up
yep and that's all the homework I really
need to do does that make sense and
similarly with productivity if your time
Horizon is like how can I get the most
important things done over the next five
years and that's reasonably well thought
through but you're reading interviews
with people on the cover of magazines if
that's even a thing anymore who are in a
mad Sprint in a zero-sum startup game to
like dominate market share and do God
knows what you're playing different
games they're just different games and
sometimes hard work alone won't get you
there I think what you choose to work on
and who you choose to work with and
actually kind of how badly you want it
which is more than just working hard or
more important than just the raw hours
you put in there are lots of people
running restaurants and uh you know kind
of meat space businesses not in the
startup world who out work start of
entrepreneurs but yet they don't succeed
or if they do succeed it's got much
lower numbers or much lower magnitudes
right and I I and I would say that a
large a large reason for that is
that Society has been has been uh sold
romantic ideas Romanticism is a very big
part of things
um Society very much seems to Value
effort effort is a big deal and effort
is sort of a a
sort of an arrival of sorts uh for for
society that look how hard I work look
how much effort I'm putting in and
therefore I'm doing I am doing the right
thing by by doing that and and the
problem that arises from that oftentimes
is those who are very efficient are
demonized because very often you will
find in every domain those who don't
work nearly as quote hard as everybody
else but they get 10 times the results
and they're considered to be lucky and
so I think I think if you look at I like
to pattern things around nature and if
you look at nature
it doesn't work hard
if you look at gravity it doesn't work
hard if you look at a tree in a leaf
falling off of a tree it doesn't work
hard if you look at the water going down
a river it doesn't work hard
so everything everything moves according
to its own rhythm
and whatever Necessities are there
they're there and therefore they need to
be worked around we're working hard is
an added extra romantic step in order to
put another feather in the cap which
says I succeeded by working hard and as
we know in a billion dollar company the
employees aren't working any harder than
a million dollar company they're just
doing the right thing
right people are doing the right things
in the right way
and and
I think one of perhaps
the the
key element of hard work which I must
say is an elephant in the room which is
rarely discussed in the world is that
hard work is considered to be a door
prize it seems to be sort of the
preparing of the bed of failure
um I think that a lot of times hard work
is done in order to have an excuse for
the mind when the Mind comes attacking
and says how come you didn't make it and
if a person is armed with the ammunition
that I have worked hard then he has an
answer for the Mind whereas if he just
said on the couch and did nothing he
would not have that ammunition so many
times people do hard work in order to
have an answer for the mind because they
know they're going to fail anyways
and externally if I'm an investor in a
company and it fails the entrepreneur
worked hard that feels more forgivable
socially than someone who's just like oh
I tried it I took a shot the market
didn't want it I gave up quickly
um I used to have an engineer who worked
for me who was absolutely brilliant and
uh he would create great products and he
would work an hour two hours a day and
then he would very blatantly sit around
watching cricket matches or playing uh
Counter-Strike which was this online
game while all the other people in the
office were just looking at him and he
just looked really lazy and people
complained to me about him all day long
but he added tons of value by creating
the right product the right place at the
right time yeah so he could get away
with it and he didn't have this pretense
of sitting around the water cooler and
talking or going to meetings he didn't
want to waste time on those things he
basically either enjoying himself or he
was working on what he thought was
effective and I think his talent to some
extent allowed him to get away with it
but just given the the era that we live
in Talent matters so much more than hard
work uh yeah and he would exemplify that
the following are some extracts from the
book The Almanac of Naval ravicant we
waste our time with short-term thinking
and busy work Warren Buffett spends a
year deciding on a day acting that act
lasts decades it's actually really
important to have empty space if you
don't have a day or two every week in
your calendar where you are not always
in meetings and you're not always busy
then you're not going to be able to
think you're not going to be able to
have good ideas for your business you're
not going to be able to make good
judgments I also encourage taking at
least one day a week preferably too
because if you budget to you will end up
with one where you just have time to
think
it's only after you are bored you have
the great ideas it's never going to be
when you're stressed or busy running
around or rushed make the time would you
like to get access to the finest nuggets
from the best non-fiction books out
there if you do you should check out
short form for disclosure short form is
not sponsoring this video but there is
an affiliate Link in the video
description why am I promoting short
form well my purpose through this
channel is to collect valuable insights
from videos of people that I deeply
admire now imagine if you can easily get
the most valuable insights from the best
non-fiction books this is what you can
find on short form a curated selection
of the best books and for each book you
can find a carefully crafted summary in
which all the book's relevant ideas are
analyzed this is why I absolutely love
to read on short form and would
recommend it to anyone as Charlie Munger
argues to have a good unsuccessful life
you have to create a mental model from
all the big ideas from all the big
disciplines and short form can be
extremely helpful for this matter as it
literally extracts all the big ideas
from the best non-fiction books helping
you to create this mental model in a
faster and more efficient way and with
these valuable ideas becoming second
nature to us over time I think we will
be able to build our best lives by
standing on the shoulders of giants as
Seer Isaac Newton would put it now the
way I personally read on short form is
to pick from my personal Library any
book that sparks my interest at that
moment and start reading it typically I
will read sometimes in the morning after
waking up sometimes at night before
going to sleep and many times I will do
a short read on the mobile phone app
when for instance I'm in a restaurant
alone waiting for the food or commuting
somewhere I created my personal Library
by quickly scan through all the books on
short form and for any book to make it
on my library it has not only to
interest me but it also must fulfill at
least one of two conditions one is that
I already know the author of the book
from an interview in some podcast or any
other source that I personally Trust and
the other is that the book itself has
been publicly recommended by people who
I deeply admire if you are interested in
short form you can visit my special link
shortfarm.com picking nuggets or use the
link in the description below to receive
unlimited access for 5 days and a 20
discount on the annual subscription if
you do choose to keep going after the
end of your trial thanks for watching if
you enjoyed the greeting content in this
video you will love our newsletter where
you can get in your email all the
greeting content plus the latest things
that I've been pondering to subscribe
always for free find the link below in
the description
[Music]
foreign